je vais commencer par vous poser une
question qui n'a strictement rien à voir
avec le titre qui est derrière moi
j'aimerais demander de lever la main aux
personnes qui pratiquent des sports
d'endurance comme par exemple vtt le
trail ou le ski alpinisme
bon je vois que je suis effectivement
pas le seul à apprécier ce genre
d'exercice de longue durée et nous
savons que lorsque nous nous engageons
dans ce type d'activités sportives
un élément est essentiel c'est de bien
nous hydrater lorsque nous arrivons un
point de ravitaillement
nous prenons soin de bien boire et de
remplir notre gourdes pour arriver
jusqu'au prochain point de
ravitaillement et il viendrait à l'idée
de personne de sauter un ravitaillement
de boire d'un seul trait le contenu de
sa gourde en se disant que en cas de
besoin il suffit simplement de s'emparer
de la gourde d'un autre concurrent
ce serait évidemment contraire aux
règles de l'éthique sportive et du fair
play
et bien pourtant c'est bien de cette
manière que nous nous comportons dans
nos sociétés occidentales
nous consommons plus de ressources
naturelles que ce que le territoire peut
nous apporter et nous puisons dans les
ressources d'autres régions du globe et
dans les ressources des générations
futures
alors pourquoi cette course effrénée à
la consommation peut-être parce que nous
cherchons le bonnart pour répondre à
cette question on peut commencer par
s'arrêter sur l'indicateur qui est
utilisé pour mesurer le bonheur et le
bien-être dans une nation cet indicateur
vous le connaissez c'est le produit
intérieur brut qui mesure en fait la
richesse ou la totalité de la richesse
qui est produite dans une région
en fait cet indicateur il nous est servi
très régulièrement pour justement mesuré
comme un étalon du bien-être et nous
sommes très influencés par ce type
d'indicateur et lorsque par exemple nous
apprenons que le pib stagne ou bien
recul nous sommes persuadés que nous
allons vers des temps difficiles
or cet indicateur il a un certain nombre
de limites et ses limites sont bien
documentés la première limite c'est
évidemment la non prise en compte de la
dimension environnementale
c'est pourquoi un autre indicateur a été
développée qui cherchent à calculer la
surface écologiquement nécessaires pour
couvrir les besoins d'une région d'une
pays un pays où de l'humanité tout
entière
cet indicateur c'est l'empreinte
écologique
selon cet indicateur l'humanité a
consommé l'ensemble des ressources
qu'elles avaient à disposition le 8 août
dernier le jour du dépassement le jour
justement à partir duquel nous n'avons
plus suffisamment de ressources et la
suisse ce jour du dépassement c'était
déjà le 18 avril dernier
autrement dit si tous les habitants du
monde vivait comme un suisse il faudrait
plus de trois planètes pour fournir les
ressources qui sont nécessaires assuré
ce train de vie nous vivons donc
clairement au détriment d'autres régions
du monde
elle détriment des générations futures
et ce constat met le doigt sur la
question de la limite à la croissance
parce que nous pouvons plus faire comme
s'il irait sur les ressources étaient
inépuisables
alors comme le dit l'économiste
américain kenneth boulding celui qui
croit que la croissance peut être
infinie dans un monde fini est soit un
fou sans un économiste alors au delà de
cette boutade
une solution existe à ce serait celle de
réussir que des couplages découplage
entre la production de la richesse et la
consommation des richesses dépendants
des ressources naturelles cette solution
elle est souvent présent dans la bouche
des responsables politiques ou
économiques pour justifier la poursuite
la poursuite de la croissance cette
croissance du thé lettre verte
le progrès technologique nous
permettrait d'arriver à un point
d'équilibré où la consommation annuelle
des ressources correspondrait à leur
disponibilité
or il faut bien constater aujourd'hui
que malgré les efforts réels accomplis
malgré les progrès aussi obtenu dans le
mode de production en matière de
consommation d'énergie ou de
consommation des ressources
nous sommes alors encore loin de réussir
ce découplage et si nous prenons en
compte l'augmentation de la population
au niveau mondial
si nous prenons en compte également le
fait
le niveau de vie augmente dans les pays
émergents ce qui s'accompagne
automatiquement une augmentation de la
production
il paraît assez illusoire de parvenir
dans un délai raisonnable à ce
découplage
il ya donc pas d'autre alternative que
de remettre fondamentalement en cause le
concept de la croissance les personnes
en fait qui s'appuie ok 1 qui
participent ou qui par dont ils
partagent en tout cas cette analyse et
qui cherchent des solutions se trouvent
en fait confronté à un énorme dilemme
parce que d'un côté la croissance elle
est pas soutenable puisque justement
elle signifie l'épuisement des
ressources naturelles mais de l'autre la
décroissance elle est socialement
destructrice elle signifie
l'effondrement du système économique le
chômage et la précarité
cet effondrement a de désastreuses
conséquences sociales dans un système où
le maintien des prestations sociales
comme l'assurance vieillesse ou
l'assurance chômage présuppose la
croissance économique
alors comment sortir de ce dilemme
croissance versus décroissance
tim jackson qui est un économiste
anglais nous propose la notion de
prospérité sans croissance il définit la
prospérité non pas comme l'accumulation
de biens matériels mais comme la
capacité d'épanouissement des hommes et
des femmes et la question qu'il pose est
celle de savoir si la prospérité au sens
de capacités d'épanouissement est
possible sans la croissance pour montrer
la pertinence de cette conception de la
croissance on peut s'appuyer sur une
étude de l' ocde qui met un rapport
l'indicateur du produit intérieur brut
avec un autre indicateur qui est celui
vivre mieux
selon cette étude passé un certain
niveau
l'augmentation du pib n'amène pas une
augmentation du sentiment de bien-être
auprès de la population
chaque point que vous avez sur ce
graphique représente la situation d'un
pays et l'on voit par exemple que la
suisse et la nouvelle-zélande ont un
niveau de bonheur similaires alors que
le produit intérieur brut par habitant
est nettement supérieur en suisse
pourtant dans les pays comme la suisse
et les pays occidentaux en général nous
cherchons constamment à amasser
davantage de biens matériels
ceci s'explique à la fois par une
logique d'appartenance nous cherchons à
avoir les mêmes attributs matériel que
les groupes auxquels nous nous
identifions est aussi une logique de
différenciation nous voulons marquer
symboliquement notre statut social par
l'achat de davantage de biens matériels
si possible plus luxueux le résultat
c'est que chacun évalue son degré de
bonheur par rapport à la situation des
autres et si votre voisin a une belle
villa avec piscine et vous un
appartement standard votre sentiment de
bonheur va diminuer c'est donc une
course sans fin ou plutôt la fin arrive
avec l'épuisement progressif des
matières premières nécessaires à la
fabrication de ces biens manufacturés
dès lors comment peut-on imaginer
enclencher une dynamique post croissance
se pose pour premièrement pour moi la
question des valeurs qui animent nos
modes de vie au quotidien
d'une certaine manière il s'agit de nous
inspirer de nos grands parents qui ne
jetez rien et qui réutilise est tout ce
qui pouvait alors certes je n'avais pas
le choix
dans une société où le superflu
n'existait pas mais en suivant leur
exemple il faut veiller à ne pas
accumuler les déchets à favoriser le
recyclage et l'économie circulaire et à
réfléchir à l'utilité de tout nouvel
achat je suis toujours très surpris de
constater comment nos enfants sont par
rapport à mon époque beaucoup plus
sensibilisés aux questions
environnementales notamment via les
programmes solaire scolaire plutôt que
solaire fait pour elle cette épreuve
solaire et que dans le même temps ils
sont continuellement bombardés de
messages publicitaires faisant passer un
message simple si tu veux être heureux
consonnes et pour sortir de cette
logique proprement schizophrénique un
changement de valeurs s'imposent
ce qu'il nous faut c'est davantage de
sobriété et de sens dans nos modes de
vie il faut nous éloigner de ce message
consumériste qui nous fait croire que le
bonheur c'est la possession de biens
matériels
le bonheur c'est davantage la richesse
une relation affective et la capacité de
réaliser nos aspirations profondes moins
de biens et plus de lien pour être la
devise de cette vie sobre mais néanmoins
heureuse ce style de vie c'est celui que
carabine ou propose sous le vocable de
sobriété heureuse
or tout autour de la planète
nous voyons poindre des signes
encourageants comme quoi le train de la
pause croissance est en marche
il existe une multitude d'initiatives à
petite échelle qui cherchent des modèles
alternatifs au système économique actuel
beaucoup d'entre vous ont vu ou en tout
cas entendu parler du film demain de
cyril dion et mélanie laurent qui
rencontraient des pionniers qui
réinvente l'agriculture l'écologie
l'énergie où la démocratie est en suisse
aussi de tels pionniers existe qui
cherchent de nouveaux modèles de fer et
de vivre ensemble qui correspondent à
cette idée de sobriété heureuse
agriculture contre contractuels jardin
urbain potager monnaies locales système
d'échangé local ise repères café etc etc
ces initiatives essaie de concrétiser la
daj penser global agir local
je mets trop vite et elles sont
absolument très importante pour assurer
le passage vers la société de demain qui
soit compatible avec les limites de
l'écosystème une question centrale se
pose cependant c'est de savoir si ces
initiatives seront suffisantes pour
justement assurer la transition vers un
monde décarboné est compatible avec la
disponibilité des ressources naturelles
j'en doute fort
j'en doute fort sans un renforcement des
cadres réglementaires
aujourd'hui pour une personne qui vit
dans un pays occidental même avec la
meilleure volonté du monde il est à peu
près impossible d'arriver à une
empreinte carbone correspondant à un kit
l'équivalent planète
le choix de la taille par don de votre
empreinte écologique individuelle dépend
aussi de décision politique en matière
de transport d'aménagement du territoire
d'énergie ou d'alimentation
il est donc extrêmement important que
les pouvoirs politiques s'engagent de
manière forte
pour élaborer et mettre en oeuvre des
programmes d'action qui réoriente de
manière significative le système socio
économique actuel en guise de conclusion
j'aimerais insister sur la nécessité
d'agir à deux niveaux le premier niveau
c'est celui que je viens d'évoquer celui
des choix collectifs et politiques qui
sont encadrés et mise en musique par les
pouvoirs politiques et qui se traduit
justement dans les politiques publiques
le deuxième niveau c'est celui des choix
individuels
reposant sur un changement de valeur
chacun chacune d'entre nous à la
possibilité de contribuer à une société
qui met au centre de son de ces valeurs
n'ont pas celle de la société de
consommation mais d'autres valeurs une
société qui privilégie lettre à l'avoir
qui privilégie le partage au gaspillage
qui privilégie lusage à la possession
après tout être heureux ses capacités de
nous épanouir
alors bien sûr être en sécurité avoir
des moyens de subsistance en suffisance
mais aussi se sentir partie prenante de
la communauté et avoir la capacité de
réaliser notre potentiel d'être humains
comme l'illustrent cette image vivent
avec la conscience que nous n'héritons
pas la terre de nos ancêtres mais que
nous l'empruntons à nos enfants
lorsque vous retournerez chez vous je
vous invite à prendre quelques minutes
pour réfléchir et répondre à cette
question primordiale pour notre avenir
et pour l'avenir de nos enfants
qu'est ce que je peux concrètement dans
mon mode de vie dans mes fonctionnement
au quotidien modifié pour favoriser
l'avènement d'une société post
croissance merci